every 37 seconds according to the FBI
statistics of 2023
sorry 2024
in July 31st it says more than 145,000
rapes took place again you multiply that
it comes to 32 seconds every 32 seconds
one rape is taking place you know I'm
giving this lecture since the last about
2 hours about 2 and a 2 hours 10
minutes. So in 2 hours more than 2 hours
already more than 120 rapes may have
taken place. Since the time I'm giving
this talk more than 120 rapes may have
taken place in in USA
in Islamic Sharia
if you rape a woman I'm if you rape a
woman you get death penalty.
Death penalty.
The Islamic system is wear hijab. A man
if he looks at a woman lower his gaze.
Woman wears the hijab. After that if a
man rapes a woman capital punishment,
death penalty. Non-Muslims say oh death
penalty in this age of science and
technology Islam is a barbaric religion.
And when I ask them the question
hypothetically suppose someone rapes
your mother and if the rapist in brought
in front of you, what punishment will
you give to the rapist? Believe me 100%
all of them said we will give him death
penalty. Some went to the extent of same
we will torture him to death. So if
someone rapes your mother you want to
give death penalty. Somebody raped
somebody else's mother you said death
penalty barbaric law. Why these double
standards? I'm asking you the question
that if you implement the Sharia
the Islamic law in USA today that any
man looks at a woman he should lower his
gaze. After that the woman wears Islamic
hijab complete body covered. The only
part that can be seen are the face and
hands up to the wrist. And after this
any man rapes a woman. Capital
punishment death penalty. I'm asking you
the question will the rate of rape in
USA will it increase? Will it remain the
same or will it decrease?
It will increase it will remain the same
or it will decrease?
Decrease. Simple answer. You don't get
award for that. you implement the
Sharia, you get results. So that the
reason Islam by doing hijab uplifts the
woman. It is the western talk of women's
liberalization
which is nothing but a disguise form of
exploitation of a body, deprivation of
honor, degradation of a soul. The
western society when it talks about
women's right, woman's liberalization,
they are nothing but changing the status
of a woman to that of a concubine
to that of a mistress to that of a
society butterfly which are mere tools
in the hands of pleasure seekers and sex
marketeers which are hidden behind the
colorful screen of art and culture. in
the name of art and culture they are
degrading our mothers degrading our
wives degrading our sisters you know
when you have the advertisement I was
told that there was advertisement of BMW
you know BMW it's supposed to be for the
youngsters a very fast car you know fast
car a competition with Mercedes I was
told there was an advertisement of BMW
and in the advertisement there was a
girl standing standing in front of the
car. A young girl standing with bikini
in front of the car and the ad read test
drive her now. Who the girl or the car?
Now who drives cars more? Men. They are
selling our daughters, selling our
wives, selling our mothers. You see an
ad of a motorcycle. Now how many women
ride motorcycles? Men ride. So what they
do with a with a motorcycle? You have a
woman. What is the woman doing in the ad
for what? Attracting. So in the name of
woman's right, what are they doing?
They're selling your daughters. They're
selling your mothers. They're selling
your wives. So be careful of this trick
of the western civilization. Islam
protects the woman, has uplifted the
woman and shows you a way how to
maintain the status of the